these are dark times for wildlife around
the world
the WWF latest living planet report says
wild animal populations are in sharp
Decline and that nowhere is the loss for
concerning than in Latin America in the
Caribbean were monitored populations of
mammals birds amphibians reptiles and
fish have declined by 94 since 1970.
this is one of the most biodiverse
regions of the world the ecosystems in
the region are changing very rapidly and
unless we do something quickly we can
face
a catastrophe humans are mostly to blame
since 1970 the region has seen dramatic
habitat loss to mainly to agricultural
expansion deforestation in the Amazon to
make space for cattle ranching is
threatening the entire world's climate
even here high in the Indian mountains
the expansion of the Agricultural
Frontier has greatly impacted the
environment potato and onion Fields dot
the landscape well over 3000 meters of
elevation endangering animals like the
spectacle bear
other Silver Linings
this is
known as Cardon esta Andy and bears main
source of food
restoration efforts like this one in
Colombus chingaza Park aim to replace
damaged environments the park has
prioritized areas that before becoming
protected were heavily altered by
Agriculture and cattle and that haven't
been able to recover alone we're slowly
recovering them now with native plants
similar programs elsewhere have proven
successful helping restore one's
threatened species like gorillas in
Africa and Brazil's dollar turtle
it is important to understand that even
though the figures are so dramatic and
and the stakes are so high uh we believe
that we still have time to make these
changes world leaders are due to meet at
the 15th Convention of biological
diversity this December a once in a
decade opportunity experts say to
implement those changes before it's too
late Alessandro Al Jazeera chingaza
Colombia